I wasn't seeing the Grateful Dead in
Hartford Connecticut and a guy that we
were with was tripping on acid and
didn't get into the show and he was just
wandering the streets of Hartford and
the valet came up and just as he was
stumbling down the street pulled up
opened the door so here you go sir and
he got in the car started driving on
started driving and the only thing in
the car and we found this out because at
the end of the night with the concert
was over he showed up at the hotel he's
like God gave me a car oh my gosh it was
Alexis the only thing in the car was a
tape he popped the tape in it was just a
Jesus tape about fulfillment in your
life you're on acid
it's the greatest thing happened
and I had to take him to the parking lot
I'm like and I went in the glove box and
I'm like God didn't give you a card this
is Kelly something brother
I don't get the Lexus